the jurogan experience i mean i say this
all the time because the uh
percentage of
graft keeps getting
higher and higher now we found out
recently that something like oh i'm
going to get the number wrong maybe you
can look it up on your magic light box
but
like 20
i think of the uh unemployment checks we
passed out during covid were complete
fraud mere pittance
[Laughter]
the uh ppp yeah oh my god so many people
got arrested for having lamborghinis and
[ __ ] right
i mean jk rowling got money no she did
it yeah for her broadway show what
because if she didn't she'd be living in
her car joe ah
she got money from that that's hilarious
everybody got money tom brady so crazy
and like
when you look at some of the percent and
like the number for uh to build a house
for the homeless in l.a
has risen to
837 thousand amir pittance bill maher
amir pins from these greedy billionaires
out there you need to talk to them all
if i'm complaining about that again to
your point about a republican idea
people would say oh you're complaining
about government spending money and my
answer is okay but is there any number
at which point i am not
tipped over into the republican side
right that i can't complain about money
that is just being stolen
right i mean we i i totally as a good
liberal i totally accept the notion that
as someone once said you cannot transfer
money except with a leaky bucket i get
it it can't be perfect
but
is it
20 what is that is there no number
for which i cannot remonstrate against
20 is a low that i mean it's even higher
than that that was only the unemployment
checks the ppp stuff was even higher
that's where the it's beautiful and
brilliant because they attach it to
something that's like like we need to
help these people we need to help these
people
these people are all losing their jobs
and their their businesses are shut down
we need to provide them with money
and then the grift the growth some of it
gets it's like let's promote and
whoever's doing it california tried to
build a railroad
they wanted to build a rail line between
la and san francisco made sense it's a
big long state and cars and blah blah
good for the environment and
it was when they finally pulled the plug
because it just became too uh
ridiculous
it was at 200 million dollars a mile now
france
france built
a france a country not unknown to uh
have unions
and workers rights very big over there
in europe
right
workers rights unions i mean they're
always on strike
always on strike in europe and they talk
with their hands okay so
france
again a very unionized country did it
for like one-seventh
that's how bad seventh yes something
like that
which again is something like 15 million
dollars a mile or whatever it was but i
mean 200 million dollars a mile and it
was only to that finally was only to
connect like bakersfield to to i don't
know
uh
pacoima or something and they couldn't
even do that were you in boston when
they were doing the big dig i was never
in boston i mean i played boston loved
playing the town but i've never lived
there but i know of it i remember 60
minutes doing a story on it yes the big
day and they did finally finish it they
did but it was so late and it was they
robbed so much money from it oh i'm sure
exactly it was that was the whole thing
about the corruption
yeah and it was really just a short
tunnel on from the airport was it under
logan one of the few airports in the
country that's right next to the city
yup like only like there in vegas
do you fly in right right and you're
like five minutes from downtown it's
awesome and i think it was not where it
was connecting yeah they were trying to
lighten up some of that traffic and they
completed it but it was like i mean they
were doing it when i was there in the
80s
and then they were still doing it when i
came back what year was the big dig
completed i want to say it was like
right at least 10 years late 2000 oh
yeah 2004 they completed yeah
so they were doing it when i lived there
i mean this look the you know when i
hear about buildback better um
okay look
certainly the country needs to get
rebuilt i mean the infrastructure is a
mess yeah
but
i'm thinking always like
when you give me a number it's like
it just seems like you pulled it out of
your ass
you know it's going to cost 1.5 billion
we know that forever
and it came in right at that
round number yeah to rebuild this or
something and and
are we going over this with a fine tooth
are there are we really seeing that it
what if we only spent 1.2 billion
uh or trillion i'm
under counting it uh what if we only
spent 1.2 trillion uh what would we be
sacrificing anything where because so
much of that money is going to
consultants yeah and just siphoned off
by all the pigs at the trough
all snorting this [ __ ] up with their big
[ __ ] snouts yeah and there's very few
people that are
saying that but that's that's exactly
what's happening that to me is not a
republican idea right it's just i mean
it's just common sense yes